the newest adaptation of Stephen King's
it has introduced yet another generation
of kids to their worst nightmares the
1990 TV mini-series scared the jorts off
of every millennial with a VCR and four
hours to spare but the 2017 version
moves the setting to the late 80s when
milk cartons paraded pictures of missing
children and the new kids on the block
were every teens guiltiest Walkman
pleasure through a wildly entertaining
funhouse of fright the losers Club comes
together to do what the adults can't and
banish evil but do they really put an
end to their shared enemy let's take a
look at what actually happens at the end
of it the losers Club is strong there's
an undercurrent of teenage rebellion
that informs the story of it we have a
group of misunderstood underappreciated
and in some cases even abused kids who
on their own are self-described losers
with a capital L billed n bro as a
stutter and bares the guilt of his
little brother's disappearance Beverly
Marsh has developed a wholly undeserved
reputation just as her father asserts
his dominion over her girlhood
in creepy and possibly even violent ways
the delightfully foul-mouthed Richie
tozer
is content to spend every second of his
spare time in the arcade Stanley you
race has constantly picked on for his
yarmulke though he can barely recite
Hebrew Mike Hanlon is a homeschooled kid
who still considered other thanks to his
race Eddie Cass Brack is whip smart but
constantly demeaned by his mother and
Ben Hanscom is the new guy whose paw
genus and affinity for the library makes
him an easy mark for the nastiest of
town bullies by coming together they
ignite a uniquely fearless and fun force
field against the demonic being that's
plagued their town for years they're not
invincible
unlike other kids who are perhaps less
subject to daily torture by their peers
the losers have been made to face their
fears almost daily from bullies to
oppressive parents to lost siblings
they've already been through the worst
life can throw at them so penny wise
despite all its tricks can only do so
much to them especially when they're
united however they do seem to have a
tendency to break apart a little too
soon as we see throughout the movie
penny wise constantly tries to separate
them to individualize the aggression
since he needs their fears to feed hi
rich what are you afraid of
close that scare tactic doesn't work so
well when they're together but apart
they are completely vulnerable at the
end of the film they agree to reunite if
the occasion calls but they'll go their
separate ways in the mean time which
can't be good news for the next victims
standing alone - they're more likely to
backtrack in their own unique ways book
readers and fans of the miniseries will
know that Stan URIs isn't going to heal
inside or out quite as well as the
others and as for bevy well Bev chooses
herself kind of apart from beating us
over the head with metaphors about her
reaching adolescence it also lays on the
love triangle element with Beverly Marsh
pretty thick not counting your grotesque
father Beverly is the apple of not one
but two pairs of eyes January embers
scribe Ben and the group's de facto
leader Bill it's Ben's kiss that summons
her from her Pennywise induced coma but
it's Bill's lips she chooses to smooch
before departure to her aunts now that
she's a self-made orphan but neither of
these fellas are important enough to
keep her around dairy Ben and Bill are
just roadblocks to her retreat from town
once she happily bypasses by the way the
bad news is that anyone familiar with
Kings riding will know that her dad
isn't the only guy who will hurt her
before it's all said and done speaking
of mr. Marsh parental plight if you
thought Disney movies had a heavy hand
of parents it went hard on the moms and
dads of dairy - Beverly greases our dad
with a toilet lid Henry Bowers knifes
his old man in the neck just for making
him look bad in front of his friends and
Mike Hanlon has lost his parents in a
horrific fire even the surviving parents
are left a little worse for wear bill
has almost completely disregarded his
parents sensitivities over their lost
son and Eddie defies his mother's orders
and trashes his placebo prescriptions
part of the point of the story is to
subvert the whole parents know best
philosophy since you know they're
largely ignoring all the missing and
murdered children around town it's
basically a big metaphor for that moment
when kids realize their parents aren't
perfect and begin to think that they can
take care of themselves instead Henry
Bowers is m.i.a on top of Georgie and
Henry's fire spraying henchmen Patrick
Hawks that are the other minor who
seemingly meets his maker of the movie
is Henry Bowers after being coaxed into
killing his old man by
of it his sudden sense of social
supremacy takes over as he goes on the
offensive against Mike Mike manages to
fight him off and pitches Henry into the
abyss of Pennywise as well which is
immeasurably deep but we shouldn't count
Henry out just yet it's a well-known
Hollywood rule that if a character's
death isn't shown on screen
you're better off assuming it didn't
happen on top of that in the story
Bowers plays a bonkers part in future
events
so his rage will likely linger just as
long as that terrible scar he sliced
into Ben's belly what about the floating
kids when Dillon the rest of the losers
come back together to rescue Beverly
from it they discover her floating
midair with her eyes glazed over after
they spring her from unconsciousness
they learned that she felt like she was
no longer alive while under the spell of
the dead lights after the losers managed
to scare penny wise away the rest of the
kids that have been floating in its
underground lair start to drop will they
to emerge alive it's hard to tell either
way though it looks like Georgie won't
be coming back to captain the SS Georgy
again any time soon although the other
lost children are potentially being
dropped to safety or at least absolution
for their folks bills left to grieve
over the yellow raincoat Georgie war
while captaining his paper boat on the
street why he isn't in the floating kid
cloud is a bit of a mystery so if you
listen closely you can probably hear the
justice for Georgie hashtag being formed
right now it isn't over although the
losers do manage to defeat it at the end
of the movie even they know the fight
isn't over we get a glimpse of it
falling apart but the creature clearly
isn't dead as a news articles been has
so carefully assembled indicate its
hunger strikes again every few decades
so it's just a matter of time before it
comes back to claim another slew of
victims in chapter 2 and when it does
everyone in the losers Club will reunite
and dairy to finish what they started
almost all of them at least thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]